foreign
monitor is a device through a really two
big ones on the market right now one is
made by a company called Dexcom and one
is made by a company called Abbott and
the latter is called the freestyle Libre
so I think it's a company that haven't
acquired many years ago
these are devices that are worn usually
on the tricep they can also be on the
abdomen and they have a little tiny
filament that is quickly shot in with a
needle into the subcutaneous space so
the filament remains after the needle
comes out and the filament sits
in a part of the body where it can
sample something called interstitial
fluid this is basically the fluid
between cells
to be clear it's not sampling the blood
so it samples the interstitial fluid and
it measures glucose level there and it's
basically calibrated to know based on
what the reading is there what the
glucose level is in the blood so a
continuous glucose monitor as its name
suggests is a way to give you real-time
information about what your blood
glucose is
as you said
for people with type 1 diabetes which
was the first use case
this is a very important innovation
because people with type 1 diabetes are
by definition dependent on insulin so
they are using insulin exogenously to do
the job of their pancreas which is no
longer working
and the pancreas of course is Like This
brilliant organ where it's the one
that's Auto regulating glucose via
insulin and when that goes away they
have to be the one to do it so now they
have this device that is at least giving
them real-time glucose information and
they can adjust insulin injections as
needed
it obviously didn't take long for that
to expand into a much much larger market
I.E 10 times the size which is people
with type 2 diabetes some of whom do
require exogenous insulin some of whom
do not but all of whom by definition
have a carbohydrate
and glucose tolerance disorder right the
very definition of type 2 diabetes is
based around
unregulated peripheral glucose
and this tool is therefore helpful right
it's helpful in first and foremost I
think knowing what to eat
you know I think historically we have
given people with type 2 diabetes
objectively horrible news and insight
with regard to what to eat you know I
mean we've just haven't really helped
them think through this problem so
the CGM makes it pretty clear that not
all foods are created equal when it
comes to managing glucose homeostasis
so everything I've said so far is
relatively straightforward I think where
we now this is a great example by the
way of medicine 3.0 versus medicine 2.0
so everything I've said so far
more or less makes sense if you're in
medicine 2.0 in fact I think we're
finally at the point where even medicine
2.0 is starting to accept the fact that
carbohydrate restriction is a really
good idea for people with type 2
diabetes
it's not the only way by the way so
caloric restriction in general will work
to improve insulin sensitivity which
therefore improves glucose regulation
but it does seem that carbohydrate
restriction as a form or a gateway to
caloric restriction has greater efficacy
than other methods
once we now talk about people without
diabetes medicine 2.0 would argue a CGM
plays no role
okay is there a randomized controlled
trial demonstrating the efficacy of CGM
in anything outside of patients with
diabetes there is not
but now we have to get into the leap of
faith that one takes when you start
triangulating between other pieces of
data so we want to start with one which
is
in a population of non-diabetics is
there any evidence that glucose levels
matter
so type 2 diabetes is defined as having
a hemoglobin A1c above 6.5 percent
hemoglobin A1c is just a way to measure
how much glucose is stuck to hemoglobin
and by knowing what that number is you
can impute what the average blood
glucose is in that individual over the
preceding three months so 6.5 which is
the cutoff
translates to an average blood glucose
of 140 milligrams per deciliter
so the question then would be
if you take two people who don't have
diabetes
one of whom has a hemoglobin A1c of 5.0
and one of whom has a hemoglobin A1c of
6.0 neither of them are diabetic
is there any difference in their
outcomes
so to put that in perspective the guy at
5.0 has an average blood glucose of
about 100 milligrams per deciliter the
person at 6.0 has an average blood
glucose about 120 milligrams per
deciliter so they're both outside that
diabetes range well the answer here was
actually pretty clear it is that there
is a difference
in fact for a non-diabetic population
the lower the average blood glucose as
estimated by hemoglobin A1c the lower
the all-cause mortality
okay so what's the implication now well
if the implication is
if you take a group of people who don't
have diabetes but want to live longer
I.E they want to lower their risk of
cancer they want to lower their risk of
cardiovascular disease they want to
lower the risk of neurodegenerative
disease
I think we can make a pretty reasonable
leap of faith that having a lower
average blood glucose is better than
having a higher average blood glucose
even if that higher average does not put
you in the range of a diabetic
so now the question becomes are there
tools to help us manage that because the
one tool would just be the A1c
you could say well I'm just going to get
my hemoglobin A1c measured every six
months
the problem with that is we know is the
hemoglobin A1c is very easy to mislead
it's very dependent on red blood cell
turnover
so the more rapidly red blood cells turn
over the more artificially low the
hemoglobin A1c will be and conversely
the longer the red blood cell sticks
around
the higher artificially the hemoglobin
A1c will be
and it's for that reason that we like to
use CGM
to actually get true measurements of
average blood glucose
when a patient who doesn't have diabetes
puts on a CGM for the first time they're
invariably
surprised there's this real learning
phase that comes you've done this Tim
you were doing this probably 10 years
ago you wore your first one everybody
goes through this I remember you know
for me it's been about eight years since
I started
at first you simply cannot believe the
things that drive your blood glucose up
could you give some examples yeah I mean
like I I remember the first time I had
razor Nets I was like it's not like I
didn't expect it to go up I didn't
expect it to go up like that right
exercise certain forms of exercise and
by the way I'm not saying this is
pathologic there's nothing wrong when
you're exercising for your glucose to
Skyrocket if you're doing tabatas or
you're doing hit workouts
it's again it's not pathological but
it's super interesting and other things
that I think are pathological is how
much your blood glucose goes up if you
had a poor night of sleep you know yeah
if you have a horrible night of sleep
your insulin sensitivity gets crushed
the next day and your glucose levels go
up well that's actually very interesting
and that you know again maybe you could
argue that adds too much stress to the
fire but it's it's an Insight
nevertheless that can help drive a
behavior change
I think in the book I cover kind of my
10 best insights from years of CGM and
myself and patients it's about different
foods and like foods high in fiber are
going to have one effect lean sources of
protein versus fatty sources of protein
all those sorts of things
ultimately I think CGM becomes a really
helpful tool for compliance it becomes a
behavioral tool we tend to gamify it a
little bit I know that when I'm wearing
CGM which I just happen to be right now
by the way I'm gonna think twice before
eating something stupid
and again it's purely just because my
personality likes to gamify things right
it's like
yeah I'm tempted to go and eat all the
leftover waffles on my kids plate but I
just know it's like ah it's gonna shoot
my blood glucose up and I like not doing
that
where I think people get into trouble
and where the counter argument is
which is a fair argument is look if you
only index on blood glucose you could
still end up doing a bunch of things
that aren't healthy you know if you ate
bacon for every meal every day your
blood glucose would not go that high
but it's probably not the healthiest
choice
and I would agree with that
but by that logic we shouldn't look at
body weight either
because by smoking cigarettes your body
weight will go down
so does that mean body weight is a lousy
measurement no it just means that any
measurement in isolation can be
ridiculous and can be gained
so we shouldn't ignore blood glucose any
more than we should ignore body weight
or body fat or body composition
we just have to understand that it's one
of many tools that we can look at in the
CGM again do I think this is like
necessary to live a longer healthier
life of course not it's simply one tool
that we have to help us understand how
to regulate one of the you know four
macronutrients